تنتقم روسيا
تقول وزاره الدفاع هنا كانها قتلت اكثر من
600 عسكريين اوكرانينيا
على نقطه مؤقته لتجمع قواتنا في ماكيفك
بجمهوريه دونيتك الشعبيه خلال الدقائق
الاولى من السنه الجديده نفذنا عمليه
الانتقاميه
الانتقام الروسي جاء بسبب مقتل 89 جنديا
روسيا بقصف اوكرانيه الضربات الروسيه
المشار اليها استهدفت منطقه الكرامه تورسك
وتلك مدينه استراتيجيه تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه وتعتبر عاصمتها المؤقته في
اقليم دنيا في الحديث يعني اكرام تيرسك
تشتد المعارك في مدينه سوليدار تسع القوات
الاوكرانيه لوقف التقدم الروسي هناك لمنع
تهديد اكرام التوست من الجهه الشرقيه
متحدث باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه قال للجزيره انه لا يمكن القول
ان سوليدار تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي لكن ثم
قلق اوكراني قادم من الشمال تزيد القوه
الروسيه الروسيه وتره المناورتهم العسكريه
تستنفر اوكرانيا لحمايه العاصمه رغم
تاكيدات بلا روسيه ان المناورات لا تهدف
للمشاركه في الحرب لكن التصريحات نفسها
سمعت من بلا روسيا وروسيا قبل احد عشر
قهرا حينها كانت الاراضي البيلاروسيه نقطه
انطلاق للحرب لا يوقف القتال احاديث
السياسيه سيجتمع الطرفان في تركيا هذا ما
يؤكده الجانب الاوكراني على الاقل حتى
الان
ستعقد تلك المباحثات في غضون ايام قليله
على الاراضي التركيه
وستركز اساسا على ملف الاسره بين الجانبين
وعوده اسرارنا الابطال
قبل انطلاقه هذه المحادثات تكررت عمليات
التبادل الاسرى 50 جنديا من كلا الجانبين
افرج عنهم ليعودوا الى ديارهم تطوى في
الوقت نفسه صفحه اول هدنه في الحرب استمرت
لست 36 ساعه بعد ان اعلن عنها الرئيس
الروسي من جانب واحد ورفضها نظيره
الاوكراني
يعلن لكريم لان القوات الروسيه ماضيه في
تحقيق اهداف عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه
المهام قيد الانجاز وروسيا ستنتصر هذا ما
يقوله النائب الاول لرئيس الديوان الرئاسي
الروسي
هكذا يتواصل القتال في الجنوب والقلق من
الشمال والبحث عن وساطه توقف الحرب ولو
مؤقته